welcome back breaking news this morning
from Texas governor Greg Abbott
responding to a federal appeals court
directing Texas to remove the buoys or
the barriers set up in the Rio Grand to
stem the flow of illegals flooding into
the state via the open border the
governor told me he is not backing down
and he will appeal that uh even up all
the way to the Supreme Court if need be
the impact of Joe Biden's border crisis
of course felt in cities and states
across the country in Arizona this
weekend the most encounters ever seen
this tweet from the Tucson sector Chief
17,500 Encounters in a single week
that's the highest the sector has ever
seen that's 2,500 people a day tomorrow
Customs and Border Protection set to
close the border crossing station in
lukeville Arizona to allow agents to be
shifted elsewhere along the border to
deal with the surge of migrants Crossing
illegally into America joining me right
now in this Sunday morning Futures
exclusive is Arizona Republican Senate
candidate Carrie Lake Carrie good to see
you thanks very much for joining us
assess what's happening in Arizona for
us Greg Abbott told us it's now the tip
of the
spear the worst the worst Border in the
whole country is the in Arizona and it's
the Tucson sector those numbers are
shocking especially when you consider
what they were a few years ago where we
barely had anybody coming across
illegally under a great policy that
President Trump had put in and now we're
seeing just one day one morning Maria
950 people poured across in the Tucson
sector in one morning and
71% were just adults this is not
families coming across and we do have
those but the majority of these people
are fighting age Men We are watching as
we're being invaded and we're seeing a
foreign army basically pour across our
border we talk a lot about B inflation
we have a b Invasion happening on the
border in Arizona and it seems like
we're not getting any attention from the
White House from DC we need to get this
border wall completed and just this week
just this week Maria and remember last
time I was on I was talking about how
the Biden administration had welded open
the gates so people could pour in just
this week we saw cartel members moving
in heavy equipment and literally
chopping down parts of the wall and a
reporter was videotaping it and they
were blowing her kisses and laughing
this is what's happening the the cartels
own and control our Southern border and
this is really in my opinion an act of
War this is incredible that we're not
seeing any response from the Biden White
House they will not return to the Trump
policies can you give us a sense of life
in Arizona as a result of this have the
neighborhoods been affected right by
that
border oh absolutely a little town
called sasabe which is right on the
Arizona Mexico border used to have a
population of 2,000 there are 15
families remaining it's in cartel
control and so this is just one small
town nogalas I just took a group of
mothers down there our moms for carrye
uh Coalition they wanted to see what was
happening and how these people were
ending up in places like New York City
on buses or on on airplanes with their
free airline ticket and going all over
the country and we went down to nog
Galis where they process all these
people and put them on buses and this is
a town that uh tells me there's seeing
people from all over the world from Asia
from China from Africa and they're
having trouble with with the people who
are just pouring onto the streets they
don't speak the language they they don't
know where to put them because it's a
town of 22,000 people they can't handle
the influx we are going to see Arizona
forever changed because of this if we
don't get serious and shut down this
illegal activity and treat the cartels
of the terrorist organizations that they
are yeah Carrie Lake I want to take a
short break and come back and ask you a
little more about elections in January 6
stay with us we're talking about Arizona
Senate candidate Carrie Lake we'll be
right back I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley Airhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis